this is gone long enough this guy spins
off weeks no calls no texts no social
media nothing
we need a new top five this week you to
think of something
hey Anna would you come up with for this
week's episode
[Music]
Disney songs Disney Disney yeah sure
just don't forget the rule I'm gonna
grab a water it's a Disney episode of
step 5 it's a Disney episode of top 5
Jim did you hear it's a Disney episode
of top 5 alright you can film anywhere
go anywhere you like just stay out of my
scene show why what's in the scene shot
it's forbidden
stay out I'm gonna get a snack
[Music]
I need to and I have to do songs
oh my god I otter are you doing that
annoying choir kid thing
[Music]
I wanted more than anything
it's the name of the show we get just
five don't you know I want so much more
but here we go
here are the top five best Disney
animated songs here on top five you get
five all the way will the new even stand
to see you okay buddy
comforting number five how far elite
crevalle oh and written by lin-manuel
Miranda the titular character Moana
sings about feeling torn between the
life she longs to lead and the one
that's expected of her although she's in
line to become cheats something beyond
the island is calling her away from the
Paradise and the people she knows and
loves
while many Disney Princesses lament
about being drawn to the unknown Moana
is actually beckoned by the ocean
literally Disney is constantly making
technological advances in animation but
Moana was uncharted territory in an
effort to get the culture and characters
right Disney formed the oceanic story
trust of local experts to consult on the
use of Polynesian culture in the film
and it was important for all the
voice-over cast to have ties to the
Pacific Islands in Maori Moana means
ocean and her realistic athletic body
type was a deliberate change from the
classic princesses smaller silhouette
lin-manuel Miranda originally wrote the
deleted song more but after being
reminded that it had to live up to felt
it was missing a certain something
Miranda sought inspiration in his
childhood bedroom and said he ultimately
landed on a more positive message of I
love it here I love my parents but why
can't I stop walking to the ocean and
fantasizing about getting out of here
which led to the song winning the 2018
Grammy for best song written for visual
media
[Music]
number four
written by Howard Ashman and Alan Menken
and recorded by Jerry Orbach and Angela
Lansbury the song focuses on the castle
staff who haven't had human contact any
years in a show-stopping Busby Berkeley
inspired number they are trying their
best to make Belle feel pampered and
welcome hoping that their warm
hospitality would be enough to convince
her to stay and lift their spell the
simple melody was first composed as a
placeholder until something more complex
was created but Menken is quoted as
saying of course after struggling I
couldn't improve on that dumb piece of
music that I wrote initially because it
was just right and got out of the way to
let Howard's lyrics shine the scene
starts simple enough but gets bigger and
more exciting as more enchanted objects
joined the dinner show it's an animation
there's no limits to how big and raucous
the party can get ain't even made a
mysteriously named gray stuff sound
appetizing sure it nearly lost the
Academy Award for best song to the title
song Beauty and the Beast but it still
made our list maybe because this number
is actually song by a French character
in a film set in 18th century France but
seriously its energy is infectious
for the moment Lumiere says mush Jam and
was ell I just can't help but sing along
oh I have the perfect accessory I don't
know why I didn't think of this earlier
you're gonna be okay if I leave you
alone right
[Music]
some song
for son
please and quiet lights stay ah I almost
couldn't find my hat because of the
lights not because of how tiny it is
number three Singh by Cliff Edwards and
written by Ned Washington and Lee
Harline Pinocchio is the fantastical
story of a mere marionette becoming a
real boy
with the blue fairy's magic and jiminy
crickets guidance a puppet can prove
himself to be brave and true and
deserving of his wish
it truly is Disney's ultimate message
magic is in the believing when you wish
upon a star plays over the opening
credits and the simple classic animation
of Jiminy Cricket becoming an official
conscience is a beautiful bookend for
the movie Pinocchio after winning an
Oscar for best song at the 1941 Academy
Awards just seven notes are now forever
linked with Disney as they are the tune
of Disney's opening logo it even
inspired a Christmas carol by the same
tune in Sweden's Norway and Denmark and
now those notes are used on Disney
cruises as horn signals that's a
powerful melody hi Anna
[Music]
I could really use your help with
something right now at the studio number
two
[Music]
[Applause]
voiced by Jodi Benson and written by
Howard Ashman and Alan Menken Ariel
yearns more than anything to be
comfortable in her own skin and discover
new ways of life more than just young
women can relate to the feeling of body
dysmorphia and the need to thrive not
just simply exist on top of its morale
and melody the scene wouldn't be what it
is without its visuals who hasn't dunked
their head underwater to let their hair
float around like aerials you can thank
animator Glen Keane who also made arrows
chachki collection of gadgets and gizmos
and whosits and whatsits and
thingamabobs the envy of all this was
the ultimate revival of the I want valid
a Disney film staple where audiences can
fall in love with the lead characters
quirks while they bare their souls
dreams and aspirations and it almost
didn't make it to the final cut of the
film executives were worried it would be
too boring for audiences but without the
success a part of your world we'd never
have gotten that song that shall not be
named and a lot of other Disney Princess
classics
[Music]
okay yeah I agree that's weird but is it
really all that worse from regular I on
a weird
[Music]
I'm just saying this because I care
you can't pull up Dreamgirls
[Music]
Oh God not Cass
today
how am I to choose between
CGI glass again
[Music]
she's gone full song time we have to
stop her
I'm more worried about where she pulled
that straight razor from how does a
steamboat Willy first uttered hot dogs
and topless yet glove rodent best buzz
with the duck and an anthropomorphic dog
dog owner become an icon symbol
household name
[Music]
and
I've got an idea
[Music]
it strikes me viewers what we satisfy
what do you mean you forget the Phantom
just five songs they will never be
satisfied is that right
they will never be satisfied I will
never be satisfied
[Applause]
one more song will help you pick one
more song
it's not about blazing trust and every
to install so you won't disappoint where
that is nev will help you pick the
Heather and me
[Music]
[Applause]
I literally said go anywhere in the
world you want just stay out of my scene
shot wow I feel almost back to normal
now hey Jim can you build me a suit of
armor from scratch sure thing
hey Jim can you build a spaceship by
tomorrow no problem hey Jim can you
harness the power of Darkness through
music you got it
just stay out of my goddamn scene chef
colors of the winds Robin Hood and Lujan
Tarzan - Tarzan make the list
look Jimmy has had some great songs
they've made us laugh cry fall in love
and even learn new words and cultures
I'd love nothing more than to say
they're all great let's move on but I
made a commitment to tell the Internet
my opinion so that they can tell me my
arbitrary decisions are wrong I know
that game Disney taught us to push
onward even when we're on shore because
the faith trust and a little pixie dust
we can overcome anything so the number
one Disney animated song is
[Laughter]
[Music]
written by Tim Rice and Elton John the
Zulu opening vocals and chants were
created and sung by South African
composer LeBeau M friendly reminder
that's a real language and not gibberish
the English lyrics are voiced by Carmen
twilly
accompanied by a choir and an array of
instruments including native percussion
this song is brilliant on so many levels
but let's start at the very beginning
although Swahili is sprinkled throughout
the rest of the film Simba Rafiki
Pumbaa in this number la bohme chose
Zulu for his lyrics
either way choosing an African language
vividly sets the scenes and the specific
opening call immediately hooks you like
hi hello sun's rising storytime
the rhythmic chanting is just repetitive
enough that you feel welcomed into
joining along the story told throughout
this catchy tune is that we're all
connected and part of something greater
than ourselves it's all-encompassing and
straightforward message has meant the
lyrics have been referenced in other
Disney films and pop culture media even
today and includes one of the most
iconic moments of a Disney film the
circle of life comes full circle by
opening and ending The Lion King in a
lovely parallel to its lyrics it was
nominated for an Academy Award alongside
Hakuna Matata and can you feel the love
tonight but lost to the ladder Elton
John actually prefers circle of life and
director Rob Minkoff has described it as
the heart of the movie and we are
inclined to agree
wow you guys were right that wasn't so
bad
told you thanks for your help Tamra
of course now are we good here because
I've places to be and cats to keep me
from going to those places
[Music]
you